- I'll never forget, like
before we took one vote,
I won't say who,
but one of their leaders
of this 20 stood up,
and McCarthy asked him like,
"What else do you guys want?
Like, let's just settle
this before we go out there
and look like fools.
What else can we do for you?"
And he just couldn't answer
it in front of everyone.
That was a really
frustrating moment.
So that's actually where
all the animosity came from,
because it felt like
it was just for show.
(pensive music)
- All right, I'm Dave Rubin,
and yes, this is a different set
because we are in the swamp.
That's right, we are
in Washington D.C.
and joining me across the table
is a former Navy Seal
and now a US congressman
representing Texas'
2nd District.
Dan Crenshaw, welcome back
to "The Rubin Report."
- Great to be here.
- In this small bunker-
- I know.
- That we are in here
in Washington D.C.
- Everything's a little
smaller out here,
you know, it's compact.
But welcome, glad
you're out here.
- I am glad to be here.
You just got in from Texas
like seven minutes ago.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, I
just flew in this morning.
- How are you feeling?
Do need a moment to
collect yourself?
- I'm waiting for the
Sudafed to kick in.
That's what I'm waiting for,
if I'm being
particularly honest.
- So this is that
you have like COVID 7
that you're bringing
to the Capitol?
It must be, I don't know.
I think it's just allergies
got into, you know,
you know how it is. I'm fine.
We'll work through it.
- I guess we shall see.
So I said to you
right when you...
You just walked in
two seconds ago,
but I said to you right
when you walked in
that we offered, I told
Republicans and Democrats alike,
about 20 on each side, that
I'm in D.C. for three days.
I will interview anyone,
and I will treat everyone with
respect and all that stuff.
Basically, every
Republican said yes,
except Mitch McConnell,
who you know, he fell
and I think he hurt
his leg or hip.
I think he might be in the
hospital at the moment,
so I'll accept that one.
And not one Democrat
even responded.
We didn't even get nos.
We got just nothing.
- Yeah.
- Does that kind of sum up
what's going on here
in D.C. these days?
- (sighs) Yeah, yeah,
it kind of does.
Let's unpack that a lot.
One, I think it's political
malfeasance on their part.
I see a lot more Republicans
go on left wing shows.
I like doing it,
I've done it a lot.
And frankly, it's
good for your...
If you only care about
catering to your own base,
it's actually
still good for that
because you base still loves
watching you say, you know,
go toe-to-toe with somebody
who disagrees with you.
- Especially if you get them.
- Right, right.
- That's what they really like.
- And it's fun, it's
intellectually stimulating.
There's a lot of other
reasons I like doing it.
But most, I mean,
most importantly,
you know I always
say like politics,
fighting in politics, what
is fighting in politics?
Fighting in politics
means persuading others.
That's the metric
by which you fight.
A lot of people think
otherwise, right?
It's just yelling and
screaming and picketing
and doing all that and maybe,
you know, dying on hills
that you knew you
were gonna die on.
That's not fighting.
That's fighting for
your base's attention.
That's a certain kind of fight.
But you're not really
fighting for them.
And so fighting
means persuading.
And the best way to persuade
is to get your point across
in a reasonable manner on a show
where you know the audience
generally disagrees with you.
So, yeah, I don't get it.
So I think it's
political malfeasance.
But to your question about it,
is it a broader indicator of
what goes on here on the Hill?
Yeah, yeah, to an extent.
I mean, you know, I'll
give you an example.
We're in E&C, Energy
and Commerce Committee,
we're marking up some bills,
and some of these
are kind of obviously
not things Democrats
will vote for,
but some of them
are not so obvious.
So here's one, like
scheduling Fentanyl analogs
as a Schedule I drug.
So that should be
pretty plain and simple.
By the way, it's all-
- Analogs,
this is like stuff that
basically acts like fentanyl
or something?
- Yeah.
An analog means it's kind
of been chemically altered
by this, yeah, exact same
basic makeup and outcome.
I'm probably getting that
somewhat scientifically wrong.
- It's bad stuff,
fentanyl, really.
- But legally speaking,
like you need to do it
so we can go after these
dealers in a cohesive way,
which is way that's not
happening right now.
Prosecutors have a really
hard time prosecuting,
not even just fentanyl,
but like fentanyl analogs,
something slightly different
that does the exact same thing.
- [Dave] Got it.
- I mean, marijuana's
a Schedule I drug.
We can debate that
separately, but the point is,
is this shouldn't be
that controversial
to make fentanyl
a Schedule I drug.
By the way, it's already
temporarily a Schedule I drug.
It expires soon.
I don't want to get too much
into this particular issue,
but the point is, it's really
not that controversial,
and fentanyl is hurting
everyone across the country.
I think two Democrats maybe
voted with us on that.
You know, the things that
should be bipartisan,
that really shouldn't
be that controversial,
they find reasons to
make them controversial.
Now, I think when we
were in the minority,
we might have done the same
thing every once in a while,
like, you know, nitpick
some silly things.
But I would say only
every once in a while.
I think it happens a
lot more with Democrats,
and it certainly happens
a lot more in the House.
The reason being
is that if you're,
you know, if you're a politician
and you're sitting
in the minority,
maybe you do kind
of like a policy,
but you also don't really want
to take heat from back home
for voting for it
from your own base,
'cause your first election's
always your primary.
You know it's gonna
pass, just vote no.
The no vote is the
easiest vote in the world,
and a lot of people just vote no
on just literally everything.
- Right.
Is it sometimes not just
that they're worried
about the base,
but they're worried about
the radicals that are here,
like that that's going to
cause more of a headache
than say they're a voter
who might be a little
more left than they are?
- Well, I don't know.
What do you mean
by radicals here?
- Well, meaning like, let's
say the squad crew is gonna
create more of a headache
for them than their own base.
That might just
be like, ah, yeah,
we'll let it slide on
this issue or something.
- Well, I same thing.
Yeah. So, so same thing.
So, so yeah.
I mean they might be afraid of
somebody in the squad tweets
something which riles
up their base back home.
It's, that's the dynamic. Yeah.
So, but it's, it's
kind of the same thing.
- Yeah. So let's do a
whole bunch of stuff.
All right. All right, let's go.
Well, first how about
we do start with this,
because I think a
really interesting
moment that we had that
you probably don't
even know about is,
I think the first time,
maybe the second time we met
was at a Turning Point USA
event during the first
Trump impeachment.
So this was right
before Christmas,
I guess this is like
2018 or something.
And I'm sure you remember
the moment where you actually
brought up your card.
- Yeah.
What wa- it was the card that,
that you said no on impeachment.
Is that what it was?
Yeah. Yeah.
So you actually brought that
up on stage to Trump in the
middle of his speech?
- Yeah.
He called you on and you brought
up the card and you signed
it for him.
That night was the first night
that I ever met Trump in person.
And that was basically when I
started saying I could support
this guy because you
supported him. And I was like,
I like Crenshaw.
I like then having
met Trump, I was like,
I like him personally. That put
some of the pieces together.
That feels like a long,
long time ago, doesn't it?
Just the way,
the way the world in 2018
felt compared to 2023.
Putting aside the
specifics of that,
just how
- Yeah.
Massively, massively different.
I've only been in
politics four years,
so I'm in my fifth year,
third term, fifth year.
I guess if you count running
for running for Congress for
about a year, you could,
I could say it's five years
in politics, but that's,
that's not very long.
- How many years
does that age you?
- I don't, I don't know.
Just turned 39, so I don't
feel like I've been aged, but,
but you know, I always don
won't admit it, but I will say,
yeah, the, the, the
atmosphere is very different.
You know, the,
the 2018 primaries were very
different than 2022 primaries,
2020 primaries or
nonexistent, at least for me,
I didn't even have a contender.
- Yeah.
And now,
now there's, there's,
there's nobody that runs without
a primary contender and can
run like way to the
right or way to the left.
So politics has gotten way
more extreme on both sides.
And it's gotten vicious and,
and angrier and it, it, it is,
it is a wildly different time.
Yeah. Everybody, I
do miss those days.
I do miss those
days a little bit.
- Is that weird that 2018
or the good old days?
I mean, that, that's
kind of bizarre.
I mean, COVID
obviously escalated
a lot of things.
- It did.
but just, but just the
general sense, I mean,
I know you well enough,
like you really do wanna sit
down and see some of these
other people.
And do you, when you see them,
like when you see some of the
progressives in Congress when
you're at the Capitol,
does anyone chat with you?
Like, are they willing to talk
even on the DL or is it just
there's nothing there?
- Yeah, yeah.
No, there, there
is, but you know,
the frustration
comes from, it's,
it's very hard to get them to
act, but don't, but, you know,
I do want people to realize
there's actually a lot more good
faith conversations
and attempts than,
than people might realize.
Doesn't always end up
where we'd like it to.
It rarely ends up where we'd
like it to, but, you know,
I mean, well, let me,
let me draw your attention
back to the Kevin McCarthy
Speakership.
- Yeah.
Vote.
- Yeah, yeah.
Not because I wanna
talk about that drama.
- It's on the list.
It's on the list.
- But, but, dammit.
But because, no,
but actually what I wanted
to bring up was the,
the hilarious bad lip
reading that came from that.
- Oh, I saw it. I saw it.
- And how often did you see
bad lip reading between like
hardcore Freedom
Caucus members and AOC?
They talk to each
other quite a bit.
You know, and like people do
talk to each other right there,
there is some yelling and
screaming publicly, but like,
I've actually,
I've gotten completely out
of the habit of going after
anyone individually
in the house.
Senate? Up for grabs.
Like, you know, Bernie
Sanders all day long.
President Biden, that's Yeah,
totally, totally free for all.
But, but I,
I try not to even go after
anyone in the house unless
absolutely necessary,
because you do have
to see them every day.
- Yeah.
And, and there, there might
be something you work on.
I mean, so like, I'm,
I'm trying to get
psychedelic treatment for
veterans and military.
AOC is a big proponent of that.
Also, we're neighbors now.
We literally, our offices,
we just got moved this
year. We are right next to
each other.
- Psychedelics all the time
I'll get to that in a minute.
We're right next to each other,
so, so it just, yeah, just,
I, I'd prefer a world where we
actually try to figure
some things out.
I'm trying to get a
bunch of Democrats
on my cartel bills right now.
I mean, that's not out
of the question yet.
Okay. And I've not
made it partisan.
I want,
I want Democrats to agree with
me that we have to go after
the cartels in Mexico.
So, I mean, there's
room, there's,
it can happen. I
still have some faith.
- Okay, so since it sounds like
you're extending a hand to AOC,
just on my show this morning
that we just
finished an hour ago,
I played a clip of
her during, you know,
given her her speech during
the parental rights and
education bill that
just got passed.
And she's screaming
how this is fascism.
- Yeah.
That if parents
know these things,
that this is fascism and
all the bill is, as I,
I basically read all
the bullet points.
It's just so that parents
know what's being taught.
- That's it.
- Their, their
reaction to this is
sort of so crazy.
- So what do you do with
that then? So you wanna,
you wanna put the
hand out there,
you wanna maybe work with her
on things that make sense?
Okay. Psychedelics
for, for veterans-
- The way it works
up here is like,
we just ignore it. Hey, you
want to co-sponsor this?
Yeah, sure. Great.
- Right.
So which is,
which is healthy actually,
because like what's what's
interesting is I do think a lot
of the emotion
leaves the room when,
when behind closed doors.
And that's a good
thing, frankly.
Like, like I,
I haven't actually specifically
talked to her about the
psychedelics bill.
I just know that she's
promoted something similar.
Like this is,
this is one of those weird
things where it's like me,
Matt Gates and AOC,
like all on the same
page about something.
- Right.
- I'm just, it's
just an example,
but you know, my
comments about X, Y,
and Z don't necessarily
need to affect
her opinion on this bill.
And her comments on X, Y, and Z
don't necessarily need
to affect my opinion on,
on this bill because, well,
it's about a greater good,
it's about getting military
people treatment that they need.
So, so it it, it can
still happen, right?
Like I it really can it
sometimes. I mean, but.
- What do you do about
the over the top writer?
Because I don't
hear that from you.
Obviously I'm more in line with
your politics, but like, I,
like she knows it's not fascism.
- Yeah.
But but then you say that,
it gets clipped everywhere.
It goes around and then,
and then that just becomes
the mainstream
thought on this thing.
- We gotta fight
back on that issue.
Like I can can fight back
on that issue against her.
I'm just saying,
I'm trying to make people
feel somewhat better about DC
That's all I'm trying to do.
I'm just saying we can
fight like hell on that.
Like if she's totally
lying and totally wrong.
And I would say
it publicly, it's,
it's completely disingenuous.
It's complete grandstanding.
It, it's, it's to, it's,
and all the Democrats have
been saying it by the way,
they're all using the same line.
Like this kind of sky
is falling rhetoric.
I'm just saying we can fight
about that and probably still
do a bill on something else
that we agree on
- Right.
Like it can happen and it
should happen. Like if,
if you let your entire
life an entire career and,
and certainly
Washington politics
be driven completely by emotion,
we'll definitely never
get anything done
because it largely
is already driven
too much by emotion.
- Right.
It's interesting because the
rhetoric is so outta whack,
with what most people think
of the country even, you know,
because most of what
they're running on,
to me seems like
radical anti-American,
radical anti-American ideas
and all of the woke stuff.
And then the other day,
Hakeem Jeffries was
suddenly talking about
American exceptionalism.
And it's like,
well, pick one guys,
But then I kind of think
that that's almost baked in.
It's like we say
every extreme thing,
so people have no freaking
clue what's going on here.
And then you get left holding
the hat like, I'm trying to-
- The intellectually honest
and consistent people, yeah.
I do get left holding the
hat a lot of times because
sometimes my own side wants
me to like really go extreme.
And I'm like, well,
that's not really intellectually
honest to what, you know,
whatever the, whatever
the example is.
And so I I tend to look for
people on the other side who
also share that same kind
of intellectual honesty and
consistency who kind of
maintain some sort of
consistent equilibrium.
AOCs not one of those people.
Like, just to be clear,
I'm just, I just.
- I don't mean to make
it about her. I just,
she says these things
and I'm like, man,
I know you don't believe
this lady. You're, you're,
I always say she's
LARPing, she's live action-
- Yeah, yeah.
It's true. It's just true.
Well, I mean,
Hakeem Jeffries said
the same stuff.
- Yeah.
On, on the par on the parents'
Bill of Rights stuff thing.
He was saying the same
things like book burning.
They want to stop
teaching the Holocaust.
- The Holocaust.
We played that one.
Like, what are you talking
about? Like, it's, it's comp,
but it's completely bananas.
I, I do, now that being said,
as just a Republican
strategist putting that hat on,
I like it when they do that
because it's so easy to debunk.
You know, it was like the,
the Georgia election law,
the Texas election laws,
those were so easy to debunk.
They looked ridiculous and
they did lose those battles.
So it, it does drive us
crazy when they do that.
But we do also have
to take a step back,
think about it unemotionally,
and think this is an
opportunity, right?
Because it's so easy
to fact check them.
- Right.
They, they've gone, they,
they've miscalculated,
they've gone too far.
It's an opportunity for us to
win over those independents
who are like, you know, I,
I don't like that
they lied to me.
I believed it for a second,
but then you showed
me this and I read it.
And it's not like that. And
that's an opportunity for us.
- So I can tell you
really want to talk about
the McCarthy fight for at
least 17 minutes, consecutive.
- 17 Minutes constant.
- Let's do, let's do, let's do
literally two minutes on it.
So you were basically in
McCarthy's camp then? It,
it was sort of getting
nasty for a couple days.
The media loved it because
Republicans were fighting
with Republicans. Okay, fine.
Are you happy in the
end result in that?
It does seem to me that the
Republicans are standing up a
little bit more and maybe the
fight did actually give it
some teeth or do you think
it was gonna end up
that way either way.
- It was gonna end up
at that way, either way.
I mean, what,
what really bugs me about
that whole week was that
nothing really changed
from day one to day five
or whatever it was.
As far as the substance of
the so-called demands, right?
This rules package we passed,
it had already been
agreed to. And it was,
it was a pretty
uncontroversial rules package.
Everybody liked it.
- So what about these
concessions that they got.
Wasn't that the whole thing?
- They're all secret.
- Yeah, yeah.
Well, those are personal
concessions that we don't quite
understand or know about.
That's, that's another
frustrating thing.
- Meaning that behind closed
doors, McCarthy was like, okay,
Matt Gates, I'll offer you
this or something into that.
- I, and I can't talk specifics
because I don't
really know exactly.
But that's, but the,
but the point is,
is the actual written down
rules, the know, supposedly,
again, I think there was
a narrative out there
that they were fighting for
this like more transparent,
better, more republican, more
democratic rules package.
But it was already agreed to
and it was this exact same
from, from start to finish.
- So the rules package
itself did not change.
- It didn't change.
Well, there was one tiny change,
which is like the
motion of AK change from
five votes to one vote,
which is like nothing.
So it's, I mean, that's
splitting hairs at that point.
So that's what was
frustrating. It was,
it was frustrating too
because I mean, you know,
I'll never forget, like
before we took one vote,
I won't say who, but, but one
other kind of leaders of this,
of this 20 stood up and
McCarthy asked him like, what,
what else do you guys want?
Like, let's just settle
this before we go out there
and look like fools.
Like what, what else
can we do for you?
And he is like,
and he just couldn't answer
it in front of everyone.
That was a really frustrating
moment. So that's,
that's actually where all the
animosity came from because it
felt like it was just for show.
- So that's interesting.
So that's the right's version
of what we were talking about
before with the left, right?
Like just the show
version of all these.
- Yeah, and it was just so,
it was just frustrating and,
and it wasn't clear to
to, to those of us who,
who were supporting and why.
Again, I can negotiate with
somebody if you're like, no,
I really want this rule to
change. And I'm like, well,
let's meet hap I can,
I can figure that,
I could wrap my
head around that.
But that just wasn't
what was happening.
And I think that's where
the animosity came from
because I'd go around
asking some of them like,
what, what else?
Like, what, I'll go,
I'll go talk to them.
What, what do you want
me to talk to them about?
Like let's just,
let's just get through this
and I wouldn't get answers.
And that, that was
really frustrating.
That's why I think the
heat got turned up so much.
But I think we're,
but I also think we're
definitely past it now that
Washington tends to be
like that. Which frankly-
- Apparently your offices are
all right next to each other.
- Yeah. Which is a-
but it's a good thing.
It's, you gotta get
over stuff, right?
You, you, you really do, so.
- Do you have a
bathroom in your office
or you have to share a
bathroom with these people too?
- No, no.
We have a bathroom
but no shower.
- Not just one in the hallway,
like?
- Yeah, yeah.
There's, there, yeah.
Every, every member
office has a bathroom.
No shower, but a bathroom.
- Okay. All right.
So you're not gonna share
a bathroom with AOC,
I assume they would be
genderless bathrooms.
- Yeah, they would definitely
be genderless. That's true.
- What, what do you make of,
of the general sense that,
and I definitely feel
this as, you know,
I left Cali and I'm
in Ca- Florida now,
that the red states
and blue states, they,
the divide right now is so wide
that it can only get wider,
at least temporarily.
Do you think that's
a fair assessment?
And are you okay with it?
If it's a fair assessment.
- No, I'm not okay with it.
I, it's bad for the country.
We need, we need honest
balance in the country.
And you need a
healthy liberal side
and a healthy conservative
side, you know?
Liberals have
their place, right?
They point out problems
with the hierarchies and the
institutions that
are set up, you know,
I think their solutions
are almost always wrong.
That's where you
need conservatives.
- Right.
I think conservative
governing philosophy is by far
the best one and
the healthiest one.
But you gotta take cues from,
from people and that's,
the liberals play a role.
Like that balance is actually
really important and that
balance is way outta
whack. And, and, and,
and we got problems in the
Republican party for sure. I, I,
I think populism is bad
mostly because it's so closely
resembles liberalism
in my opinion, but.
- Meaning that they'll use
government to get whatever it is
- That yeah, it just
untethered from principle.
It's generally telling people
what they want to hear.
And that's how I
define populism.
And that's certainly how
I observe it in practice.
- So this would
be like where you,
you and Tucker definitely
see that differently.
- Yeah, yeah.
I'm not really sure what
he's for in many cases.
I mean, you know,
he hates me because I think
we should defend America and
stand up to Russia
like that. That's why,
that's why he doesn't like me.
I'm not sure what
else we disagree on.
He's probably is more
willing to use the powers of
government in a very
non-conservative way
on certain things.
I don't, I wanna put
words in his mouth.
We'd have to really
specific on the issue.
But just in general, when
you look at populists
here's an example.
I mean, I remember this
is the 2020 election
where we were talking about
free paychecks, you know,
$2000 checks to everyone,
universal paychecks.
And I remember the far right
being like, you gotta do this.
This is what needs to be done.
This is, you know, and it is,
I was like, well why
not 3000, why not 4000?
The entire point of being a
conservative is to have some
kind of tethered principle,
some anchoring there
that has to be,
it's called limiting principles.
And so that's populism, right?
Because I'm like,
oh, oh, you know,
is it gonna be popular to give
everyone a $2000 check? Yes.
Does that make it
the right thing? No.
Like, so, so that's
what I mean by that.
And liberalism just,
it just is the,
is the political mechanism
for that kind of mentality,
generally speaking.
- But, do you see any,
are there, where are
the liberals, though?
I mean, I see, I see
socialists mostly.
You probably saw that
incredible moment on real time a
couple weeks ago when Bill
- Yeah.
basically said to Bernie,
what's the difference
between equity and equality?
And he literally said
he didn't know, I mean,
that should've-
- That was interesting 'cause
it's like he's
never thought of it.
- Right
You know, cause we,
we have that conversation
in our circles
quite a bit.
- Yeah.
Like, you know, we nitpick
at their philosophy.
We really, really
try to understand
their psychology and philosophy.
And they never try to understand
conservatives. Like they,
they just, they actually
default to demonization.
It's actually appalling.
But also it's a huge advantage
for us because I always know
what they're gonna say.
I always know how they're
gonna make their point.
And that was such a
good example of like,
Bernie's never even really
thought of that. That that,
that it's an important
difference. You know?
And Bill eventually got him
to kind of say what we would
want him to say, you know,
it's like about outcome.
- But he was like, blah,
like, here you fool.
- Right? He's just
never thought of it.
- Yeah.
Which was, which was crazy.
So it's proof that
they're driven by like,
that the left is
driven by populism
and kind of what feels
good at the moment
sort of mentality, right?
This kind of outsized
like pathological
sense of compassion.
Like you can have too
much compassion, right?
That will, that will,
I dunno to kind of just screw
up your entire framing of a
problem and then
how you approach it.
- You've read some
Jordan Peterson.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Mutual friend.
- You've done many
things with him, so wait,
I wanna back up to though,
to Russia for just a sec.
So, cause I think we
have a little bit of a,
a difference opinion here.
As a general rule,
I believe in strength to stop
your enemies and I believe in
deterrence and all
of those things.
There's something that feels
different to me about this
thing because we're so screwed
up internally right now.
Like because of inflation and
all of the craziness of the
last couple years that we're
giving all of this money and
that people are just like, yes,
give them four more tanks
and three more planes and pay
for this. And it's like, we
know that's not gonna end it.
And he has nukes. So it's not,
so I think I probably
agree with you on like the,
the blue sky like policy.
What should foreign
policy look like?
I just think we have a bunch
of incompetent buffoons running
this and, and that changes
my equation a little bit.
- Maybe you could always
find a reason, you know, to,
to want to solve this problem
instead of that problem.
But they're not mutually
exclusive, you know?
giving money to Ukraine
for weapons has,
has zero inflationary
effect for one.
I think you'd have a much higher
inflationary effect if you
looked at the counterfactual.
So if we're gonna say we
should never support Ukraine,
you do have to operate with
a counterfactual in mind.
And that counterfactual is
this. We never, okay, fine.
We never gave 'em anything.
They were never our ally.
We don't care if Russia
should takes 'em over
for all we care, you know,
doesn't concern us at all.
So that means they never-
- I'm not saying
all that, but I get,
I get what your point is.
- But we have to say that.
Because, because that is the,
the obvious counterfactual. So,
so that means Russia
takes over, right?
That means we don't do anything.
We never gave 'em javelins,
we never gave 'em stingers,
we never gave 'em the weapons
that helped them fend the
Russians off at and
in the battle of Kyiv.
And we never trained them for
the last few years. Right.
We never did any of that.
Russia would win and also
their military would be intact.
So you'd have an intact
Russian military with a,
with a, with now an
emboldened Putin.
Because now the
population's way behind him,
they weren't really behind-
They're not really behind him
now because he is not winning
and they don't like being
conscripted into his army.
But in the counterfactual,
they're winning.
They haven't lost to so much.
And now they're on the borders
of Poland, Slovakia, Hungary,
Romania, all NATO countries
with an imperialistic mindset.
I mean, and Putin's talked
many times about, you know,
freeing Russian ethnic
Russians throughout Europe.
Estonia has a lot of those.
Latvia has a lot of
those, NATO countries.
So there's, there's,
I think we have to take
Putin at his word, right?
We rarely do for some reason.
I mean, he says he
is gonna do things.
We should accept his word and,
and acknowledge that
he's going to do it.
You know, and this, he's always,
he's always played war games
that are offensive in nature.
They're never defensive.
Like this idea that he's been
afraid of NATO and he has to
like, create a buffer zone
that's complete nonsense.
They never practice
defending Russia
because they know
they don't need to.
It's not a reasonable concern.
Also, NATO's just not,
not designed that way.
And he knows that he,
he's not a stupid man,
he's a very rational guy,
but he's rational within
a Russian context, okay?
So he is not, we,
Westerners look at
what's happening.
They're like, "This is
completely irrational."
Yeah, by our standards
because we operate
in this sort of
rules based order.
We believe in sort of
goodwill and partnerships.
That's not how he thinks. He
lives in like the 18th century.
He does see himself,
he's talked about this.
He sees himself as this sort
of second coming of the czars.
So he sees himself
as an imperialist
and he believes in strength.
Like he respects you
because you're strong.
And if you're not strong,
he believes it's his right
to take things from you.
Which is how he sees Ukraine.
He doesn't see- He
sees them as subhuman.
And so for less than 10%
of our defense budget,
which is which is the
money we're talking about,
we can just make that
scenario not happen.
That's a pretty good deal.
It's a damn good investment.
So we just completely
decimated the Russian military.
Now, is it purely competent?
Well, look, Biden's
not actually doing
every little bit of this,
thank God,
- Right.
'cause he is incompetent
and he was incompetent with
Afghanistan in a massive way.
He didn't listen
to his military.
In this case he is
listening to his military.
Now he's still not,
he's still making mistakes
in the sense that, you know,
he should have done more
quicker and ended this,
you do have to
escalate to deescalate
and then call for a resolution.
That's, that's
the strategy here.
That should be what the
president should be saying.
But he's not really saying
much. And that's the problem.
And I think that's why
people like you are like,
I don't think you're
competent in this.
So I get that.
- Well, right.
'Cause it's also that every
week we play a clip of him
or blinking or one
of these guys saying,
well they shouldn't
negotiate and they,
and we should just continue.
And it's like, well,
- Yeah, that's like.
I just don't think, you know,
right before the election, was
it right before the election?
I think Mitch McConnell
said that the Ukraine war is
number one on Republican voters'
minds. And it was like, I,
I played that clip on my show
and literally the amount of
email I got of people being
like, it's not in my top 20.
Not to say what you just said is
not important.
- Yeah.
But people when they're like,
I can't order a freaking couch
'cause it now takes six months.
or like, you know.
- Yeah.
It annoys people.
I get that.
- Yeah.
And certainly that's not our
most important thing in the
world, but it it is important.
I I, yeah, I don't like the,
I don't like being
in the business of
overstating it either.
Which is I think what
you're referring to.
- So what does the, what
does the end look like then?
Like what, because I,
to me it's just like,
we're just gonna
keep doing this.
Like every couple weeks
we'll be like, all right,
there's more money.
Couple more tanks.
- The only defense yes. Of
those kind of comments is you,
you gotta remember
who's listening.
It's not just your
voters, it's the Russians.
And so that's actually,
that's, that's,
that's the part of strategic
deterrence. Make them think,
we'll just never stop,
'cause that has to factor
into his calculations as well.
Now what? But I'm,
Since I'm not at the top
levels of the government,
I'm a little bit more free
to say what should happen.
And it's kinda what I just said.
I think it should escalate to
deescalate and you do have to
force some kind of
resolution that just
stabilizes the situation.
It's not ultimately important
to Americans that like a few
miles of Ukrainian
territory is impeded upon,
at least to the voters.
But you do have to
set up permanent
deterrents in this case.
And you actually should think
it's pretty important that
Ukraine doesn't get
taken over by Russia.
There, there's been a,
there's a lot of narrative on
our own side that it's just
this backwater country that
doesn't matter that that's
economically speaking
just totally false.
You know, I'll give
you some examples.
I mean, it is the bread basket
of the world for a reason.
They're still doing those
exports. So there's a reason,
like things haven't
completely gone to hell yet.
I think it produces most
of the world's neon,
which is used for
semiconductors.
So that that's in
every single thing.
Every little part of
your life is based there.
Quite a bit of our steel or,
or at least a pig iron
ore comes from Ukraine.
So there's a lot of
resources there that,
there's a reason Putin wants it.
Again, he's rational
by Russian standards.
There's a reason he wants this
particular area and for him
to control that much is, is,
is not in America's interest.
Now, is it worth us fighting
a nuclear war over it?
No, it didn't say that either.
But we're not, and we're
not even close to that.
We've not lost a
single American,
we don't plan to lose
a single American.
We've just written a check for
less than 10% of our defense.
Like, I mean that's-
- Right.
So, so it was just
speaking of cost benefit,
I think there's massive
benefits here with,
with very little costs.
You also have to look at
how China looks at this.
- That's what I was, yeah.
So when you saw him
with Xi last week,
like does that concern you that
somehow now we've just sort
of like forged
this new alliance?
- It was already forged.
I mean, I mean look,
remember they were meeting
right before Putin invaded.
I mean they were, they were,
they were planning
this together.
Xi encourages this because
he wants to see what
the West's reaction is.
So, Xi is doing his own kind
of red cell observation.
Do you know what I
mean by red cell?
- Not totally.
Okay.
So a red cell is just
like a military term,
when we do kind of a
maybe red cell's not even
the right term in this case.
Now I've overcomplicated the
conversation. But in any,
anyways, it's, it's,
it's, Xi gets to,
Xi gets to observe
a scenario, right?
Where, where there's
an unjust invasion
and he gets to observe what
the West's reaction is, okay?
Because he wants to
invade Taiwan obviously.
And he wants to know how long
the West will stay together,
how much we're
willing to invest.
He wants to know these things.
And so of course he's
gonna encourage it.
It's in his interest that that
Putin is successful and that
we quit because then that, that,
that get that and in
effect, green lights,
his invasion of Taiwan.
That's what he's looking for.
Now, you've, you really
don't want Taiwan
to be taken over by
the Chinese, right?
Just, just simply for the
semiconductor problem.
You also don't wanna
go to war over it.
So the best method
here is, is prevention.
And that's, that's a
whole other conversation
about what we could do
better to prevent that.
- I jumped completely from the,
the red blue thing into the,
into Ukraine. But what do
we do to mitigate that?
if we wanna stay the United
States and we're watching these
states, I mean, when I go back
to Cali now, I'm like, man,
this place has nothing to do
with anything that I believe in
or wanna be part of it.
It seems ridiculous to me.
- Well, oh, I don't know,
maybe I'll go back to
what I said earlier.
You gotta be persuasive, right?
We've gotta convince
like moderate liberals
and independents
that conservatism is just a,
a simply a better way forward.
You know, there's a tendency
in American politics
to look to the worst
of the other side
and they're like,
you know, so they'll,
they'll pick the person on the
other side they hate the most
and be like, this is why
I can't be with you guys.
And because we, because we,
and it's because we so rarely
talk about our principles.
I think that's a
problem. That's why I,
I tend to try to talk in
philosophical terms to,
to get people, like, let's
start from the foundation here.
Lemme explain to you how I get
to this policy that you think
is just the devil.
You know, when it's not.
And you know, let's go
from there, I mean...
- I like this situation. Are
your offices is literally like,
you share a wall with AOC?
Is it that next door?
- Yeah, yeah.
Like literally you share a wall.
- Yeah.
I think this could be
- My office probably shares
a wall with her staff,
but yeah. But, but yes.
- But in essence, yes,
I like that maybe,
like, if anyone can do
it, it's probably you.
Like, bring her to something
ballpark saying maybe.
- It's hard to
say, you know, it-
- I know you'll try, I
know you'll try, at least.
I sense you'll try.
- Yeah.
Well I'll, I'll at least,
like, like I said, I'll,
I'll at least try on like
this one issue that I know she
already agrees with.
- Right.
But you're not gonna convince
people who are that far left.
Just to be clear. Like
you, you know, my, my when,
when I say I'm talking to
Democrats about my cart-
- Can you just define fascism,
like, you're pretty good
about flying in terms,
how about that?
Alright, what one
more for you then.
Obviously the big thing on,
on the Republican side is,
is the Trump-DeSantis thing
that seems to be happening.
DeSantis has not announced,
but it all seems like it's
going in that direction.
I voted for Trump. I like Trump,
I love what's
happening in Florida.
Like I'm trying to do it
as honestly as possible.
And I think we need a
shift in generations.
Like there's a whole
series of things.
What do you make of this and
how worried are you that this
just like implodes the whole
thing and we get Joe Biden
another 30 years.
- I'm very worried that it
implodes and that there's
massive division in the party.
I'm staying out of it.
I mean, I'm not gonna
comment one way or the other
who I like better.
- Yeah.
Because everybody's
just a little angry
and upset at each other.
And there, there's really
no benefit to doing so.
It's early. It's early too, so.
You know, DeSantis, will
he, will he announce?
Yeah, I'm pretty sure he will,
but he hasn't, there's
only a handful that have,
and so we'll, we'll,
we'll let this play out.
But I'm absolutely worried for
our party and, and you know,
the, how, how these
divisions manifest and,
and more importantly,
what it means for our
potential for victory in 2024.
So we need to get it together.
- Crenshaw, I can't let
you leave on another
worried comment, because
my policy around here is
I gotta give something
positive to end.
- Let's talk about going to war,
let's talk about gonna
war with the cartels.
- Fine.
Finish,
- There we go.
- finish strong.
- Yeah.
Yeah, that's something that'll
bring, bring us all together.
I think every, well it
brings Republicans together.
I'm trying to make it
bring Democrats together.
So, you know,
I've recently- was threatened
by the president of Mexico.
- Oh right.
And he's getting,
he's gonna, yeah, yeah.
He's gonna, he's gonna
come campaign against me.
I thought that was
mildly hilarious.
It actually shows how bad
this situation really is.
So, you know, this
is our number one
tactical security threat.
We have strategic security
threats, Russia, China,
those are strategic
security threats,
long-term security threats
as far as, you know,
keeping chaos out of the world
because that affects Americans.
But this, this is a,
this is a near term tactical
major security threat,
right on our border. These
cartels are small armies.
They can battle
the Mexican army.
They've bought off much
of Mexican government.
You know what, what
my reaction to AMLO
saying what he said to me
was, wow, tell me you're,
tell me you're bought off by
the cartels without telling me
you're bought off
by the cartels.
I mean, 'cause I
never came after him.
He just on, you know,
I go after the cartels.
I don't go after Democrats on
this either because I'm trying
to get them on this bill that
would simply give Biden the
authorization for
military force.
It doesn't mean you
roll tanks in tomorrow,
it just means you
have authorization.
Ideally we do that with
Mexico just like we've done in
many other operations
around the world.
So I think this is a, this is,
this is my major focus is,
is the cartels in Mexico,
The fentanyl they're producing
and shipping across our border
poisoning, murdering
Americans every single day.
- I'll make you a deal.
I will focus on that a little
more so you get a little juice
behind you and you will walk
over to AOCs office within the
next couple weeks and tell
her to respond to my email.
- Okay? Alright.
Will you please respond
to Dave's email?
He's a very nice guy.
Thanks Dave.
- If you're looking for
more honest and thoughtful
conversations about politics
instead of mindless dribble,
check out our politics playlist.
And if you wanna watch full
interviews on a variety of
topics, watch our
full episode playlist.
All right over here.
And to get notified
of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and
click the notification bell.